in the interest of disclosure eric and i
may be working together on explanations
of the mathematical concepts behind
geometric unity as for what specific
form it's undecided but consider this a
potential teaser
as always you can click on the timestamp
in the description or over here to skip
this longish introduction today's
theolocution involves eric weinstein and
mick west on the topic of the evidence
of ufos as well as the relationship
between skeptics debunkers disclosure
the public perception and scientific
inquiry eric weinstein is the inventor
of geometric unity a proposed theory of
everything as well as being an advocate
for ufo disclosure mick west is a
science writer as well as skeptical
investigator who's had some choice words
to say about the disclosed footage of
the phenomenon as well as being the
creator behind the software that at
least purportedly substantiates his
analysis mick west is also the author of
escaping the rabbit hole how to debunk
conspiracy theories using facts logic
and respect a special thank you goes out
to mick because he was in the hot seat
with the difficult task of defending the
quote-unquote skeptical community's
perceived tenor against those who see
some non-terrain explanation behind ufos
the links to their respective podcasts
that is the portal by eric and tales
from the rabbit hole by mick can be
found in the description another podcast
that's terribly worth subscribing to is
ross coldheart's need to know with zebel
and the links to that are in the
description as well my name is kurt
jaimungle i'm a torontonian filmmaker
with a background in mathematical
physics dedicated to the explication of
the variegated terrain of theories of
everything from a mainly theoretical
physics perspective but as well as
analyzing consciousness and determining
what constitutive role does that have to
play in reality and the fundamental laws
provided these laws exist at all and are
knowable to us a theo locution stands in
contrast to a standard debate format
which i dislike because it's destructive
and not furthering generally speaking
instead theo locutions are attempts to
understand one another and even advance
the interlocutor's position fructifying
in real time rather than maligning if
you'd like to hear more podcasts from
the toe channel then do consider going
to patreon.com
curtjamongle that's
c-u-r-t-j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l supporting
with whatever you can if you like as the
sponsors and the patrons are the only
reason that i'm able to bring
conversations of this quality and depth
consistently as this is what i'm able to
do full time now today's sponsor is
brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some information
theory because i would like to do a deep
dive in constructor theory so i took
brilliance courses on random variables
distributions and knowledge slash
uncertainty after taking that course i
could finally see why entropy is defined
the way it is it's an extremely natural
formula there are plenty of courses for
example there's also group theory so
many of you are interested in the
standard model and you hear that the
gauge the internal gauge symmetries are
u1 cross su 2 cross su 3. those are
examples of what are called lead groups
visit brilliant.org
toe t-o-e to get 20 off the annual
subscription and i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons and i
think you'll be greatly surprised at the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects that you previously had an
extremely difficult time grocking thank
you and enjoy this theo locution of eric
weinstein and mick west
all right
so by the way have any of you met prior
to this
uh no we've just kind of interacted on
twitter a little bit but we've never
actually uh uh had any direct
conversation before
why don't we start with mick what is it
that you respect about eric and then
eric what is it that you respect about
mick
well i really respect eric's uh
intellect and the way he uh kind of
frames issues in a weather rather
sophisticated way i think
uh i think it's he brings a lot to the
table and that he has a a background in
science and he understands the processes
of science and he understands scientists
and i also very much like his
perspective that we should be doing more
uh to promote science particularly
physics
because physics you know essentially is
the bedrock of all all the scientists
all the sciences
and it's something that's going to be
fundamental to the future of the human
race and so i really appreciate
that
that kind of drive that he has to to
improve science
eric
i guess
what i believe is that uh mick is um
quite fearless
in going up against
the uh
very determined
uh ufo community that is clear in its
beliefs
i believe that there is a certain amount
of complete nonsense out there which
needs to be
destroyed and i think that that's
yeoman's work
so it's kind of thankless in many ways
even if it gives you some notoriety and
i feel like mick has been willing to
blow apart things that should not
have gotten the kind of mind share in
the world that they did
and i think that
anybody having the courage of their
convictions and being willing to stand
alone and be a lightning rod
for controversy and particularly
directed hatred of a group
takes a lot of
courage and
inguinal fortitude so i really
appreciate that about me
thank you
i may as well tell you both what i
respect about each of you eric you have
unexampled views on almost every topic
and it reminds me of this comedian
patrice o'neil it's one of my favorite
comedians he's no longer around whenever
you would ask him well what's your
opinion on
on something for which 99 of people
agree upon and you think you would
predict his response it would be
original and it would make you think and
i find that quality is something that
you also have eric and that it's
difficult to summarize what you say
usually that happens for people who are
more avant-garde in their thinking and
then for mick i like that your
actions follow your words so you're not
just deriding you the ufo community and
then leaving it
you follow it with tens and tens or
hundreds of hours of
work put into your website and
simulations and software so it's not
just saying hey this clearly can't be
the case and then you run away
yeah no it's uh it's it's it's it's not
a job i must set that up from the
beginning this isn't something that
anybody pays me to do
this is something i'm doing of my own
kind of interest partly because i just
find it fascinating but partly because i
think it's also you know kind of an
important topic uh you know i'm more
into
i guess conspiracy theories in general
as being an important topic but ufos is
a subset of that especially the way it
intersects with government so yeah i'm
not being paid to do this
but i do think it's important
all right mick do you see yourself as a
skeptic or a debunker and what's the
difference between those two
uh that's that's a very loaded question
in a way because uh for a long time i've
struggled with uh the term debunker
i wrote an article for skeptical
inquirer a while back called in defense
of debunking
when i i laid out the case for using the
term debunker and
my argument there was that if you show
something to be false
then you have debunked it and no one has
a problem with the word debunked in the
past tense
uh if someone says oh yeah that has been
debunked everyone's like oh okay then
that's been debunked and you know
assuming that they can demonstrate that
is true
but if you're doing it in a in the
present tense in the active sense
uh people tend to think that means that
you are trying to get to
a certain predetermined outcome which is
very much not what i'm doing when
especially in the realm of ufos now if i
was doing something like investigating
flat earth then yes i would say that i'm
trying to get to a predetermined outcome
because you know we've already done the
work to determine that the earth is not
flat so you know we're trying to figure
out the best way of explaining why it's
not flat but with ufos you know i'm more
of an investigator
and yeah often in the course of that
investigation i do debunk things people
make a claim about a particular video so
this demonstrates amazing g-forces
and
i will end up debunking that but that's
in the process of investigation now
skepticism
i see
the problem with skepticism is that it's
not really a verb it's not really
something that you do do you skeptic
something
you can debunk things but you can't
skeptic them skepticism is kind of more
of a of an attitude
so in a way i feel
skepticism is a little bit more negative
if you really get down to it but in
popular usage debunking takes on this
negative term so i've actually
actually after i talked to ryan graves
one of the pilots uh he told me the the
fact that i had debunking in my twitter
profile was a turn off for him and he
didn't want to talk to me initially
because of that
and because of that that was kind of
like the straw that broke the camel's
back and now i've decided to remove that
from my twitter profile and just focus
on you know being a skeptical
investigator who does sometimes end up
debunking things but debunking isn't a
label
a debunker isn't really a label that i
would uh actively use
eric what's the salutary role for
skepticism and do you see mick as being
a proponent of that
i'm confused by mick
and
i don't understand mick but consider
that i really haven't been out here for
very long
in ufo territory
it's not a region of the world
uh the intellectual landscape that i
expected to visit or spend any time in
so
as of
two years ago i was pretty much the guy
who shut down every ufo conversation
that people wanted to have around me
um
and so that was sort of my role in my
own intellectual set
and then um i came to believe that
clearly i had been the target
of miss and disinformation from all
sides
and then it became this question of well
what the hell is this topic if it's not
what i thought it was
and i guess i've been very surprised to
have
encountered mick in the twitter sphere
so
i don't think of him as particularly
gunning for me or out out to get me but
there is some
aspect of
he's
he sees himself in a role um with
respect to
a community which and let me just say
the the positive part of this
there's a lot of complete nonsense in
ufo land that
is not only false
but is also bunk in the sense that
somebody
a bunko artist needed to create the bunk
in order for the bunk to exist it's not
a question if somebody saw a mylar
balloon and got confused
so there's really a role for debunking
and in particular i think there's a role
for debunking aimed at our government um
because clearly the government has been
up to bunk
either then or now or both but it can't
be neither
there has to be some aspect of this that
is bunk
um
where i get very confused is for those
of us who have never particularly
focused on an incident or a set of
people or
a group of names i
mean i am very confused as to what mick
is trying to police
um
because at the moment i'm just saying
like i'm confused and apparently
somehow it's not
good enough to be confused
one must also be clear that this is
nonsense and i'm not at all clear that
this is not so
well you're confused about me i can
maybe i can clear up what my position is
what i'm actually trying to do here and
partly as i'm not really trying to do
anything you know the i got into this
this this field simply as a hobby
i originally started
investigating debunking the chemtrails
conspiracy theory like over 10 years ago
after i i left the the video game
industry and i had a lot of spare time
on my hands and i was like learning to
fly and doing things like that
and it was just very interesting to me
and it was like essentially a series of
puzzles
and people say like why do you spend so
much time on this well i kind of respond
to that with uh
some people have hobbies some people
spend an inaudible amount of time on
things like
running model trains or painting little
figurines or making funny dolls
or
skydiving or whatever whatever their
hobby happens to be
and this this topic here
investigating things happens to be
something that really intersected
with my my skill set
uh of
debugging things like figuring things
out what's the root cause root cause
analysis of things
and my interest in science i've always
been interested in popular science and
so it's just something i just kind of
got sucked into and it kind of spread
out and you know eventually i kind of
settled down in a way on this ufo thing
because
it's so
interesting in terms of the mathematics
the geometry and the physics you know
very simple physics you know just simple
newtonian stuff linear algebra and
things like that it's nothing
complicated but it's stuff that i i used
in my previous career and so i kind of
enjoy flexing those muscles and recently
i've been enjoying flexing my muscles
programming simulations
uh and i do also enjoy the interactions
with people i like talking to people i
like talking to people who believe
people who used to believe and you know
to a certain degree talking to skeptics
although you know to be honest a lot of
the skeptics are you know rather the
grumpy boring types that you know don't
have a lot of fun and the ufo people are
much more fun best one i ever had was uh
the flat earth conference i went to that
was a real party but yeah i'm i'm not
trying to do anything huge here
uh perhaps in the broader sense of
debunking conspiracies i want to make
the world a better place by having fewer
conspiracies out there
but the vast majority of what i do it's
like oh an interesting ufo video let's
have a look at it or you know this guy
said something let's see if it checks
out yeah it's kind of like this this fun
hobby that ends up touching on things
that might be fairly important
well it gives us a great deal of insight
so let me just to mix it up with you
say you've mentioned chemtrails
and you've mentioned flat earth
and you've mentioned ufos and the fun of
interacting with people and debunking
and making the world a better place and
i think i'm starting to see the outline
of where this problem occurs
so
the the key issue in a lot of these
things is type 1 versus type 2 error
chemtrails sounds pretty stupid and to
be honest little green men seems pretty
dumb to me too
to say nothing of the flat earth which
seems idiotic and preposterous
but if you ask me the idea of the
tuskegee medical experiment an untreated
syphilis sounds dumb
oh really the government's gonna allow
people to go untreated into tertiary
syphilis or
um we're actually going to kill fred
hampton in his bed through cointelpro
using the cook county sheriff's
department or we're going to trade
you know
drugs for arms with iranians and the
iran contra all of these things sound
dumb to me
because they're clearly preposterous
and
the concern that i have is that i don't
believe in ghosts and i don't believe in
the loch ness monster
and i do believe in j edgar hoover's fbi
as an agent
agency you know filled with evil
targeting
ordinary americans for their political
beliefs up to and including their
personal destruction and death including
using
our free press to plant stories and
destroy people
and so i imagine you in all of these
contexts
and i imagine you as the guy who said oh
really you think the fbi is going to
come up with the story and plant it in
the los angeles times the gene seberg
has been a leading actress has been
impregnated and cuckolded
her husband with a leading black panther
yeah tell me another one eric except
that really happened
and
this is where i start to get into my
issue which is
i really don't like the personal
destruction of individuals
who are trying to sort out fact from
fish fiction and type 1 versus type 2
error and incredible and preposterous
stories that are clearly not true
and incredible and preposterous stories
that are absolutely true
and the debunking energy of this is fun
it's a hobby it's a pastime with other
people on the other side of this who are
not bunco artists
who've come to believe things some of
those things may be completely false
some of those things may be
confusions
some of those things may be true and
we're going to call them false because
they're actually
part of a storyline for example you
could easily imagine in the ufo case
that we would use a ufo cover story to
disguise the testing of stealth
technology before anyone knew that we
were working on it
and if so if i see a giant black wedge
in the sky that looks like no airplane
ever
you know and was thin as a pancake
i would be needing in need of debunking
simply because the government had
created a bunko story i had seen
something and then i had to be
personally destroyed in order to make
sure that the program stayed secret
so i guess i i
to be blunt about it i see this as
punting the responsibilities of a human
being a scientist and a skeptic to take
a side in this it's like the really
difficult time thing is decision
boundaries type one versus type two
errors trying to figure out who's active
in trying to bunk things
that needs to be debunked who's confused
who needs to be made unconfused and who
is saying that they're seeing something
that needs to be followed up and
not necessarily having their reputation
destroyed because somebody wants to in
your own words flex
i don't find the flexing fun and to be
in it didn't say flex
you did say flex
i don't well it's not a word i actually
use so uh not say something about
flexing your own oh flexing my muscles
but it's not like flex as in like you
know
yes i know but uh
for me flexing actually means the same
thing as stretching okay but right now i
just went through exactly one of these
moments where i tried to remember
something you'd said
and then you told me that you don't use
that as a phrase then i happen to be
able to recall in a sense the sense that
you mentioned
no yeah
i think you did say it in the original
sense from which the the internet term
flex comes from so i don't think that's
even correct
so my point to you is
i don't enjoy the feeling in my body
right now which is i've just
contradicted you
you assured me that that's not a term
that you use
we had yeah perhaps
at most a misunderstanding
but the f
of something but the feeling of somebody
saying
no you're wrong and thinking that that's
fun your initial description of your
activities as a hobby
i don't much care for this as a hobby if
it's a duty
because the world is going to be filled
up with nonsense i actually appreciate
that i want to be very clear about that
but the fun of interacting with people
many of whom
are scared
i've seen people close to and
filled with tears i've seen people who
feel that their lives have been
destroyed because they have made contact
with something that they can't talk
about me too and i wouldn't be very
clear here like i'm not doing that for
fun when i talk to people uh and i have
a podcast uh telstra on the rabbit hole
where i talk to people who are you know
believers or experiences or whatever
and i'm very respectful and i think the
vast majority of people who
who are in that position who are very
upset you know there are people who
have developed serious uh
emotional issues because of their
experiences and that's something i very
much respect and i certainly would not
in in any sense say i'm having fun
uh debunking that in fact there's some
people that i i prefer not to even talk
to because i know that they are they are
so sensitive when i'm talking about fun
i'm talking about things like geometry
and programming and figuring out what's
in this video and those things should be
things that are essentially neutral uh
from a personal perspective i know some
people don't like it
but i i try to always keep that personal
aspect of it separate i enjoy talking to
people uh just simply from the
interactions with people but i'm always
very sensitive
to people's feelings i haven't enjoyed
our interactions
uh well that's that's perhaps you know
my my interaction style could do with
some improvement but you know when i
said mine could as well and i look
forward to improving i haven't blocked
you i'm just saying that the feeling
i've had
is
i was effectively lied to that there was
absolutely no there there
i believed it
what are you referring to
uh the idea i thought that
in essence the entire ufo
um story could just be dismissed with
the back of a hand that this is
complete nonsense
oh i i
i'm kind of with you in a sense on that
uh that's
aspect of it i think that the ufo story
is something that needs investigating
and i think what we have here is
something i think that perhaps you have
been doing here is kind of simplifying a
very complex subject down into like you
know it's either one thing or the other
uh like you would
you would you were describing my um you
know debunking
as as you know some some kind of you
know calling i can't remember exactly
what you said but uh
i think you were kind of describing it
at a very high level you know as if what
i am doing is trying to prove that
little green men don't exist and that
all these people are wrong
uh when i look at it i look at it kind
of the micro level uh
where i am looking at individual cases
i'm trying to figure out what's actually
going on in this individual case now
someone asked me my opinion about the
broader uh implications of this then
i'll give that but that's not my goal
that's not what i'm actually trying to
do
and when you're describing you know what
i'm doing
you're describing like it's as if i have
some kind of big agenda trying to
you know debunk ufos as a whole
really i'm just looking at individual
things okay
look
i think if you look before
two years ago you'll find no discussion
you know i discuss almost everything
under the sun zero discussion of ufos
i don't think i have any particular
history of oh do you can you understand
in the in the uh go fast video this but
on the nimitz video you know such and
such and fragra said this and but
lazarus said that like this whole world
i'm just not even a part of
uh
i know that there's somebody with the
last name of greer i couldn't tell you
the first name i don't know whether
they're pro or anti it's like i'm really
not part of this world
um what i have learned
is
that the amount of indirect evidence
that something is up and something
i have to say when i don't when i say
something i don't mean little green men
and i mean little green men not as
little or green or men but just as the
phrase to
aliens yeah
it's like
what could be up could easily be just a
disinformation campaign it could be a
cover for us a stealth program it's
there's something up
and
i don't need
to please you to tell you what
weights are on the on the branches of
the decision tree
i simply need to say boy was i confused
this isn't just a bunch of people
seeking attention
uh or some sort of promo stunt for a
spielberg film gone wrong
it's
it's quite a bit larger than that it's a
tremendous amount of indirect evidence
that the basic puzzle as i understand it
and again i'm i'm new here
um
is that there is
zero convincing direct evidence where
there's a chain of custody with the data
um
and
you know we it's not only a question of
a few seconds of video but you know very
detailed multiple sensor data everything
sort of fits in in some kind of a way
that you could actually say there's no
there's essentially no way of faking
this yeah there's almost none of that
to my knowledge there is no convincing
proof in the public sphere
so that's the big thing that argues for
the fact that this is not about ufos or
um in the sense of
uh aliens and little green men and
sentient intelligence
the thing that goes in the other
direction though
is just how much indirect evidence there
is
that something has been going on
and
how
willing we've been to destroy people
who've been willing to poke at this and
if you believe that the direct evidence
argument is effectively a pretty good
argument that nothing's here because so
many of us have cameras it's kind of
amazing
that nobody ever captures something
that's really really convincing
um that doesn't make sense to me
uh if you believe that story you've got
a big problem with the level of indirect
evidence if you believe the indirect
evidence you have the reverse problem
for god's sakes why is there no
absolutely crystal clear
data set that has slipped into the
public's hands so
whatever your resolution to that puzzle
is
i'm usually in the position where i come
up with too many explanations
this is one of the only topics i've ever
met where a creative brain can't come up
with a single explanation to fit all
these data points
well i think the reason for it is that
there isn't a single explanation and i
think it's a mistake to try to look for
one i think there's a a lot of things
that explain
both the actions of uh government and
the military and the various interested
parties like you know to the stars
academy and people like that
and there's a variety of explanations
for the sightings that people are having
the evidence
that arises and trying to kind of shoot
on it into either you know one big
cluster or one big cover-up uh perhaps
there's a degree of both in that perhaps
the government does use things like ufo
stories to
uh
allow them to be out there at least for
distractions from other things
uh and certainly like we know that
there's a variety of different
interesting parties within the
government there are there's infighting
there's there's uh a degree of
incompetence uh which i think you know
it's kind of endemic anywhere there's
corruption uh there's kind of you know
there's back dealing there's people who
are doing things for their friends in
government
and there's a variety of things and i i
think it's not
going to be simple if we actually figure
out you know what's going on with this
whole ufo thing i think you're going to
be looking at hundreds and
maybe thousands of different data points
that and there won't be like one big
smoking gun
either way wait a second let's just take
one category of ufo things so we have
mylar balloons and swamp gas and
disinformation campaigns and
experimental aircrafts and drones and
and in
non-friendly nations blah blah blah
let's just take everything that
is a normal sounding explanation that
can account for this and let's take
various claimed ufo encounters
and
attribute those to those explanations
that we're all prepared to accept
include some of the sightings
or experiences is there anything left
over
in your opinion
that's really unsettled
because it's a question of overlapping
explanations for like
it could be the chinese or it could be
the russians or it could be the iranians
or it could be swamp gas
it's like
i get that those are all the same style
of explanations i mean if if the the
government says they have 143
unsolved or 142 now they just said they
were the chief scientists just said they
sold one yesterday
uh but they those are actually cases
that are unsolved that they were unable
to determine what they actually are and
the likely explanation is simply that
there isn't enough data so there's
definitely going to be lots of
interesting things out there uh they
probably fit into one of the the
categories of things like airborne
clutter or atmospheric effects or
heavenly bodies or planes and
misidentifications things like that but
we can't determine what they actually
are
but what we don't have is what you said
earlier we don't have something that's
unambiguously
unusual something that demonstrates
advanced aerodynamic capabilities or
something that seems to defy the known
laws of physics but uh we certainly have
lots of unresolved things
i don't think that necessarily means
anything i think that's that's just
something that's inevitable and i think
that when we have you know more detailed
inspections of data sets
it's just going to revolve it's going to
resolve more thing not resolve it's
going to bring up things like that rv
loeb's new program the project gala
layout program he's is trying to set up
his telescopes and these sensors which
will detect when something's there and
then they'll zoom in on it and then
they'll take photographs of it and he
says maybe they'll see the you know made
in uh
made in outer space sticker on it but
probably what's going to happen is just
you're going to get more blurry photos
and they will be undetermined so
it's inevitable but let's get back to
your
superposition argument
we all agree that it's going to be a
superposition that's not the interesting
you know if it could be iran or it could
be china that's a superposition of
different explanations no one says that
all drones have to come from one country
the key issue isn't
superpositions of
different
mundane categories the key issue is
is there anything at the moment that
argues in your mind
for
an exotic explanation time traveling
humans visitors from another galaxy et
cetera et cetera
not in my mind no and
i i'm curious as to
why people individual that's part of my
interest actually is is trying to figure
out why people believe uh what they what
they believe why do people believe weird
things why do people think that time
traveling
uh humans from the future is actually a
reasonable explanation why do they think
that uh trickster spirits
is is a reasonable explanation i know
there's some fairly serious people who
use the term trickster uh as uh
kind of an explanation for ufos there's
some kind of trickster from another
dimension who's has come over you know
jack valet i think is a big proponent of
this and uh
his his uh his colleague um
i forget his name now but uh uh
that they they talk about tricksters
what is it that actually makes people
who are at one point serious scientists
go over to thinking that uh
essentially poltergeists from outer
space is a reasonable explanation for
things you know i don't say that to i
mean that sounds like i'm mocking them
but
that's actually the type of things they
did
it does sound like i'm mocking them yes
i know but uh that's an unfortunate look
i don't want to trap you and mick i
don't trap you in language if it sounds
that way to your ears well let's just
real quick real quick i want to address
that point like i'm not mocking them i'm
essentially trying to accurately
describe
their positions and it's unfortunate
that uh with a lot of these things if
you talk about say flat earth if you try
to describe the position it comes across
as ridiculous
when someone is is using tricksters from
another dimension as an explanation for
ufos it comes across as ridiculous but
it's actually what they say
but
let's try this carefully
let me imagine
that you and i are living on north
sentinel island
uh in the andaman chain in the indian
ocean
and
i say you know i can't help but feel
that there's a bigger world out there
and that every time something tries to
contact us there's a force an unseen
force that stops them from making
contact and we've become really
belligerent we keep throwing spears and
shooting arrows at anything that
approaches our beaches but i have this
feeling that
a power
exists
that is screening all contact and that
there's an entire world of people like
us and dissimilar from us who want to
contact us and you say
oh really
you think there's like a federation that
really cares about us and stops us from
being contacted and they're tricksters
in the sense that they uh they prevent
landings uh so that we will think that
we are isolated and alone in the world
and you know i'm trying to describe
india
and you're making fun of the fact that
i'm trying to describe india i don't
have the word india because i've never
spoken a word of hindi or i don't know
that i'm probably an indian citizen
according to the world
but north sentinel island has one of
these problems which is
it's got effectively a an unseen force
called india that acts in some sense as
a trickster to make sure that they're
not in good copernican position to be
able to observe the world
and
here i've got mick west
talking about this in terms of what
sounds ridiculous because it is
ridiculous and the answer is no it's not
ridiculous at all
no it's not but if i was on north
central ireland i would be pointing out
all the evidence that we have for this
thing you know we see contrails from
jets flying overhead we see boats
uh occasionally people come and they
land on the island and there's trouble
so we've got a lot of evidence that uh
these things actually exist you know if
they if they were in a
completely isolated island in the middle
of the ocean and they were hypothesizing
about something with no evidence then
that would be a different thing so it's
all about the evidence they they have
evidence on north sentinel ireland for
the hypothesis that you propose and i
believe that we have evidence both for
and against
active visitation by intelligent life
that we do not perceive as any of our
own civilizations not very good evidence
they have very good evidence on north
central island because they can actually
see people
they can actually see things like planes
they can see boats
you know very often in in science
experiments i've watched people throw
out the outliers because they have a
feeling that you're allowed to throw out
the outliers and sometimes the outliers
are bad pieces of information
this occurs in you know the tao theta
puzzle story that richard feynman tells
about the asymmetry of the weak force
and sometimes
you know sometimes it's real information
sometimes it's an artifact of the
environmental setup
what outliers you think are being thrown
out of the ufo sphere
what outliers do you think have been
thrown out of the ufo spirit we don't
have like amazing videos that are just
being thrown out because they're
well i think you and i are disagreeing
about something more fundamental
my feeling is is that
there's a sort of debunking energy
versus a scientific energy and
i kind of like debunking to be honest
when it's your great aunt's
poltergeist in her second home
you know there's a story about a kid who
committed suicide in 1913 and now haunts
the house
i don't want to have to deal with that
stuff scientifically i don't want to
have to write an nsf grant and and get
the university of puget sound involved
or whatever
there's a role for debunking and then
there's the problem of the debunkers and
i think we have to actually talk about
debunking
as kind of an anti-social negative
movement i want to
sorry
let me i think that's ridiculous though
i think that frankly i think it's
ridiculous because you know i i i
identify as a debunker
you know i've said there are problems
with that term so unless you're talking
about somebody else i assume you're
talking about me
no no i'm talking about
there's a movement of people right all
right so do you see me as being part of
that movement well you've been curious
in my mind you're certainly
and again i'm i'm not angling for
anything in particular i'm not a
takedown artist i don't love
interpersonal conflict it feels to me
like
in the world of debunkers and i've now
met them in multiple fields
you are
one of the most disciplined and to be
honest one of the most charitable
that i've met
now so this isn't principally about mick
west
the problem that i have with this as a
movement first of all
skepticism doesn't pay very well i've
talked to michael shermer about this
um it's very hard to to do the yeoman's
work of skepticism and make it
entertaining
so the problem with most of the skeptic
movement is that you start off trying to
say look i'm just trying to keep the
crap out of science so that we can have
a conversation that's not always
cluttered with somebody's ghost stories
or whatnot okay so that's very important
particularly with respect to religion
religion always wants to intrude
then you get into this problem which is
you have to spice up your skepticism
because it's not really
tremendously entertaining so that's when
you typically get snark you get
condescension you get
stigma and all of those things tend to
chase good people
out of these discussions much the way
good people are chased out of politics
there's an idea that politics belongs to
people who don't mind having five
private investigators scurrying about
over their life to interview every ex
boyfriend or girlfriend uh you know to
dig up any dirt to be printed on the
front page of the new york times my
feeling about this is a lot of us who
would like to run for office like to see
other people run for office are very
angry
that the political crowd is taking this
over and it's like if you can't stand
the heat get out of the kitchen well the
same thing is true with ufos
my feeling is i want to hear from a lot
more people
and one of the things that i want no i
want to hear from a lot more people and
one of the things that i want them to
know
is that there are smart caring people
who as long as they're not telling some
bs story and as long as they're willing
to reconsider their views don't need to
be debunked
because that stigma
is antithetical to agree antithetical to
science well just be careful what you
agreed to because i don't want to know
it all sounds good so far okay uh
the implications
why don't you recapitulate what eric
said so that we can see if there is
indeed agreement
well um
yeah i think eric is saying essentially
that um
there's a certain type of
criticism of various fields and we're
talking about ufo in particular here
the type of criticism that is identified
as the debunking community
that has a stifling uh effect like a
negative effect um the uh the chilling
effect
uh which prevents discussion because
people
feel like they're being attacked they
feel like they're being ridiculed people
don't like that a lot of people involved
uh have a deeply emotional connection to
it and so they're not going to come
forward if they feel that they are going
to be ridiculed
and and i agree that that is a problem
and i think
in in the broader sense it's been a
problem at the government level
and the the historically the government
has basically completely ignored the
the ufo problem the ufo issue if you
look at what the faa was doing say even
just 10 years ago
they basically said call this paranormal
hotline it was a ufo hotline but it
still went to a site which also dealt
with with ghosts and things like that
so there has been this kind of ridicule
of the issue and i really don't think
that you know i or indeed most skeptics
uh who actually look into ufos uh are
really part of that type of ridicule we
actually investigate cases in great
depth
we we do the math we do the work we
sometimes go out and do the field work
we do recreation experiments we try to
figure things out i've interviewed lots
of eyewitnesses i do it with the
greatest respect and i trust that what
they are telling me is what they believe
to be true
so i i would really welcome
people to come forward with with
evidence why would you trust that i
would imagine that some of those people
are not to be trusted in their attention
trust is my simply my default position
well i usually assume from the start
that people are going to tell the truth
because that's been my experience that
most people do now that has burned me in
in the past a little bit uh like people
will will you know do overtures to you
and then they'll turn around uh but most
of the time you catch more flies with
honey i'm not going to catch flies it's
probably a poor analogy but it's uh i i
i'm a naturally a nice guy i when i talk
to people you know i i empathize with
them and i understand that you know it's
it's a difficult thing to talk about
uh so
well let me ask you a question
i don't have the sense that there's any
real reason for any animosity between
you and myself to be honest at all no
why do i have the takeaway of what are
you doing in my timeline again
in other words
i would imagine
that in a slightly different world
universe a prime rather than a where we
live
you and i would be naturally allied on
this topic
scientific type people who have a
natural skepticism of things okay so i
didn't come looking for you and then
multiple times you've sort of
entered in
and you're you know you're talking in
specific about
lou elisondo and somebody who i think
i've never mentioned the name chris
mellon i hope i'm
that it's yeah chris mellon i remember
everybody's name he's a government
official who's part of the whole
invisible college type thing okay
so
what
what is it that you perceive me as doing
that needs to be
sort of minded
well you uh make bold
declarative statements about this you
know this is a huge deal i believe this
is the thing where i started to interact
with you that you thought it was like a
huge deal that either there are some
kind of you know advanced technology
flying around that we don't know what it
is
or there's some kind of uh
big you know cluster starting with harry
reid yeah i can't remember exactly what
you said i think you you were something
along those lines
and i think at the time i was basically
saying what i am saying now that it is
more complicated than that and the
reason i i interacted with you and i
probably wouldn't with just some random
person is that you have reach you know
you've got a lot of followers you've got
a very popular podcast you you've
written you've written books you know
you're quite well known and people take
what you said
and you become hero within the ufo
community and they listen to what you
said so i feel like nie's addressing
eric's written a book
i haven't gotten the coffee
it's a secret invisible book um
but sorry okay okay
so
so mick
i i stand by my statement this is a huge
big deal and i don't mean this ufos i
mean this decision tree has no
boring branch
yeah i i'm actually kind of in a little
way coming around a little bit more to
that than i was at the time when i first
disagreed with you first of all i really
appreciate you saying that
yeah yeah well it's uh
it's not not in a victory lap kind of a
way just in terms of evolution yeah i
have no problem changing my opinion when
new data arrives
yeah it well let me explain why i've
kind of come around a little bit i think
it's it's really being the increasing
uh looks behind the curtain that we've
been having i guess over the last year
and actually culminating just a couple
of days ago and you probably didn't have
a chance to look at it i sent the email
yesterday
about travis taylor the chief scientist
of the uap task force
and
he's someone who was hired by the lead
of the european task force to be the
chief scientist and he contributed to
this uap report that we're all familiar
with
but he's also the chief scientist on a
tv show the secrets of skinwalker ranch
and he's also been a visiting scientist
on other things like ancient aliens and
he had a tv show called uh
redneck rockets i think or backyard
rockets
scientists
he's he's
really very unexpected as the choice of
someone who
wants to be neutrally investigating uh
ufos because on the one hand he's at
skinwalker ranch on tv
basically promoting the idea that
there's some kind of weird
interdimensional tricksters coming
through and doing weird things at
skinwalker ranch whilst at the same time
he's supposed to be soberly
investigating the evidence
and writing up reports and briefing
congress it really doesn't make any
sense and i was that was frankly i was
flabbergasted uh when the news used
broke a couple of days ago that he was
in fact the chief scientist
do you know this person
uh i've i've talked to him a little bit
online but i i don't i don't know him
personally no
so i have spoken to eric baird who is
out there on that skinwalker ranch
history channel
project and i've spoken to brandon who i
know a little bit who owns the ranch
yeah
i've spoken to brandon too
pardon me i interviewed him for my
podcast i interviewed brandon for my
podcast i'm we're kind of friendly on on
twitter too yeah yeah
um
i i have to tell you that part of their
problem is that they believe
and i
i don't think they're lying to me i
could be wrong
let me just no i'm gonna be careful
about this
i believe that they think they've seen
enough weird stuff that it's effectively
almost impossible to keep this air of
detachment going
and if you if you look carefully on
travis's uh
you know statements
he basically has gotten to the point
where he's like we've seen so much weird
stuff here
you know i never would have believed
this two summers ago but this and that
he's still careful to say we don't know
what's going on
but
he's certainly decamped
into a position where he's saying i've
now seen so much weird unexplainable
unexplainable stuff that i cannot
affect the same position of studied
neutrality that would occur before i
tutored my bayesian prior
and this is
not necessarily a knock against him in
other words if the i
i have been told by multiple people who
do not strike me as
charlatans
i only wish you've seen what we have
because we're wasting time in this
conversation
now i have noted on social media that i
am tired of being told that i'm going to
be shown something
and then like lucy in the football
i never managed to make contact with the
football and as a science as a phd in
stem
i feel duty bound to report that i have
been
spun up several times only to be wound
down
and told that it's got to be deferred
because of some meeting or some change
in plans so
i have no idea whether this outreach is
a form of disinformation in which
well-meaning individuals are
constantly put in some sort of
tantalus like situation um
[Music]
was one of those invitations to go to
skinwalker
oh i've i've had multiple invitations to
go to skin marker from brandon
and have you taken up on that no i
haven't and for reasons that you may
find amusing
um
one of the things that i did was consult
with some people about the safety issues
of
um this ufo stuff
and they said
um
things that i wasn't really prepared for
one of which
a particular individual said to me
there is absolute tissue damage that we
can record
that comes out of stories of encounters
and you make what you want of the
encounter story but it is completely
consistent with
our
biopsies and
our understanding of
what cell death has occurred
which i found really interesting i mean
here i'm talking to
published scientists it sounds like
evidence it sounds like evidence
but my point would be whether or not i
understand that as aliens or whether or
not i understand that is that there's a
uranium deposit or who knows what
i i don't know enough about
secret weapons or geology or who knows
what yeah you know i do know that
i've been warned
um
that bad things happen to people who get
too close to some of this stuff
well it doesn't stop them filming a tv
show though
yeah i brandon actually invited me it
may not stop me from going out either
yeah no brandon has invited me maybe we
should go together and then we can
compare notes uh brandon has invited me
and i have not uh i recently reached out
to him to try to take you up on him but
is being like busy and hasn't really got
back to me yet but you know i would
still like to go to skiing walker and if
you're interested i'm potentially
willing to consider it off air i asked
mick if he would be willing to engage in
so-called ce5 that is close encounters
of the fifth kind if someone offered to
perform it with him and time was
sufficiently limited travel paid for it
was done by someone known for their
consistency in this regard etc as this
is a technique which purportedly
reliably induces quote unquote contact
mick responded i would go i think there
are probably no supernatural phenomenon
or visiting aliens but if i'm going to
criticize something then it's only fair
that i try to fully understand what
people are experiencing by observing
them experiencing it and maybe even get
a sense of it for myself
there's some topics i would love to
actually hear your take on as an expert
because i'm not one
one thing i found very distressing about
this whole topic is i was willing to
reconsider
my ufo position
separately from
attendant positions which
i don't really want to get into so
the first thing that's very hard to
separate off is this cattle mutilation
claim
right yeah so in other words
you think you just want to talk about
um
actually i'll go in later to the issue
about why i'm interested in ufos
for for scientific reasons but
assume that assume that you just want to
talk about ufos you get into cattle
mutilation and then you get into
progressively weirder and weirder
sounding stuff that i'm not excited
about
the least exciting thing for me is this
remote viewing stuff
right it's interesting from a historical
perspective say more from the uh the
actions of the government the government
did research into remote viewing and in
reaction to the russians doing research
into remote viewing
i believe back in the 50s or 60s project
stargate and this was a real thing
so i think you know even though it's
something that sounds kind of
somewhat ridiculous it's something
that's actually
bubbled its way to the top in a way that
you know ufos are bubbling their way up
now it's uh uh it's something that's
you know men who stare at goats the film
is based on on real real events
so you know these these things
they they don't sound interesting and
they're a bit silly
but they had consequences if the door is
open for ufos being a real phenomenon
whatever let's place brackets and just
say it's an extraordinary phenomenon
then
why does that not open the door to other
extraordinary phenomenon which is also
attested to by high-ranking
individuals and there are government
studies such as remote viewing why is it
provoking an unfavorable reaction from
you i i don't know whether you saw my
interaction with hal put off on the
topic of predicting the markets
yeah so why don't
you well
no it was a bit more subtle than that
his claim was that he was able to
predict the markets in order to
effectively replace a bake sale or
something at a local school
and by getting 10
he could make somebody else i forget 260
thousand dollars and he could get 26 000
which is all he needed then he stopped
predicting the markets
the typical energy around that would go
like dude if you could become rich why
wouldn't you do it right
that's not my energy
my energy is difficult
my energy is
if you could do this reliably you could
settle so many debates
by
proving like you assume you don't care
about money
and assume whatever this that and the
other thing
you do care about credibility
and you could increase your credibility
by inviting people onto your private jet
to take you to your private islands et
cetera et cetera
by just doing this relentlessly
and then
that conversation didn't go anywhere now
if you notice in
jesse's cut of that interaction
i stayed on that point doggedly um
and he cut a lot of it out but you see
him say this thing where he says like i
think we've i think we've addressed this
issue
um
but i was always trying to be
polite i was not trying to take hal
to task in a way that led him
look ridiculous i was you know i i find
this claim disturbing
like you i don't want to let these
claims in if they cloud our judgment
it's very important to me that we not
have nonsense claims
i don't want to say he's a liar i don't
want to say i believe this to be true i
don't know what to make of it i'm
probably backing off of it before i
do more
damage
i don't like
these other claims kurt
because the cattle mutilations are the
ones that are closest to sounding like
ufos
and the remote viewing
sounds like a different force carrier in
other words if if you imagine
that you want
kurt where are you currently toronto
toronto yeah and mick you are in
sacramento sacramento so somehow we're
all having this conversation on a screen
in real time almost
and this is only possible because of
photons and electrons
imagine that there are new force
carriers like photons that can be used
to transmit information that can go
through
i don't know sea water who knows what
it's possible that you could get a new
physics
to explain remote viewing and that
microtubules are
you know
uh antenna in the brain and blah blah
blah it's not completely outside of the
realm of possibility but it's also
pretty far-fetched
right and
it's important to be able to say this
sounds like total nonsense without
necessarily needing to destroy somebody
in the process
it sounds like nonsense i think you're
you know you're polite uh sorry uh that
your polite questioning uh of how put
off was the right thing you were
pressuring him there and it's not really
about why don't you use this to make
loads of money because you could very
easily
give a reason why you don't need the
money it's it's why don't you
demonstrate this this amazing new
physics or this amazing new phenomena to
science
if remote viewing was actually a
demonstrable thing
it would be one of the most incredible
revolutions in science in um you know
ever really it would be as you just
described perhaps a new force of physics
an entirely new understanding of
consciousness and the brain
it would be a big deal
and yet hal put off is just like um yeah
i kind of got bored of doing that and
didn't took too much time i wanted to do
other things it was it seemed ridiculous
i couldn't understand the answers that
came back yeah yeah
mick do you see remote viewing as
equally far-fetched as taking ufos
seriously as some extra
ordinary phenomenon i i see it as
equally un-based in evidence you know if
it's if it's something that could be
done it would be huge and you know to
that extent you can understand why
people in the military perhaps people
with a little bit of magical thinking uh
went for it if you hear that the
russians are doing something and they're
having success doing something you know
the you know obviously the
intelligence wasn't quite as uh as good
as you might might like you're getting
these these things out of russia
then yeah why not
stick a team on trying to figure out
whether it's real or not but neither the
russians found anything nor they know
the americans let me come up with a plot
a more plausible
explanation
we know that for example leon theremin
who discovered uh
capacitance as a musical instrument
which bears his name
was in the sharyashka prison system
which is these country club prisons for
like stem
geniuses to work on soviet projects
while well well in prison
and he came up with if i'm not mistaken
a means of
watching the vibrations of a window pane
and using it as a microphone so that you
could tell what was going on in the u.s
embassy for example
and you know i believe there was also a
plaque that was a listening device
imagine you had lots of ways in to
listening
to the americans inside of the russian
embassy
more broadly
i would easily think about developing
remote viewing as an explanation for how
how could they have known that
yeah right
yeah it could be
a fine cover story because you would
actually be able to tell what
conversation somebody was having in
private
um
as a result
they're using magic to explain away
their own incompetence in a way that
that plaque that you referred to was was
on the wall for i think you know several
years before they discovered it had a
microphone in it and so they know that
secrets were getting out and rather than
actually go down the actual
real route of like sweeping their
embassy for bugs
they started perhaps you know there's
this kind of magical thinking and that
remote viewing was real and we should
investigate it
so
in such a case i would understand why
there would be a story
and this is one of the reasons that
i think a lot of these stories got
formed in a time before the internet
and so the problem with a story like
this is is that you can
it was easier to keep
brittle structures of narrative together
before there were so many people chiming
in and you could crowdsource data or
understandings of
what was going on
and that's that's what's happening i
think to a degree now with whenever
the secret evidence comes out
it gets examined by a very large number
of people and quite often gets resolved
and when that happens it essentially
reveals the incompetence
of the people who have been looking into
it like there's this green triangle uh
video that's been knocking around for
quite some time your lens aperture
pointer yeah yeah and it's it's
basically been you know 100 conclusively
shown that this is just an artifact of
the camera and the vast majority of the
the green triangles in this video were
just stars and yet we have uh statements
and leaks uh that uh say that they
thought that these
stars in the sky that appeared
triangular were actually some kind of
flying craft and and even some kind of
flying triangular craft
but when it gets released and especially
the high quality video when that gets
released it's pretty much apparent what
it is to people who who are familiar
with these things
so someone made the argument that
perhaps you know they're not releasing
this data partly because they don't want
to be shown up
they're afraid of
the things being solved and then looking
stupid which is kind of what happened
with this green triangle thing you know
the the lead scientist of the uap task
force travis taylor he didn't think
that they were they were uh
stars and then i kind of explained it to
him in a bit more detail and now he's
changed his mind and how he thinks that
they are but you know for years the uap
task force was laboring under this
misapprehension that these these flying
uh these flying things were green
triangles when they were in fact
identifiable stars that we can name and
show on a star map so there's a real
issue there of cover your ass which
might be uh cooling things down a little
well one of one of my questions is why
do we not have our best people
on this and this was my point i think
where you and i came in contact in some
sense in twitter where i was saying
if somebody is claiming that we cannot
control airspace that is sensitive from
a military perspective
um
is that what they're claiming though i
mean they're not claiming we can't
control it they're claiming that we
occasionally see things in there that we
can't identify and we we haven't
determined that they are you know under
control by an intelligent entity
uh so it's more of an issue of we have
clutter in our airspace and we don't
know what it is
you and i have heard different things
i have heard that we cannot control our
airspace
that these things are not that uncommon
that
these are actually
um much more frequently found near
sensitive military installations and
exercises that they can potentially turn
off and on nuclear devices well that's
these are these are claims beyond
there
how do i even put this
one of the things that you don't know
about in this world until you actually
start talking to people
is
which of these stories are highly
conserved
through people who don't seem to even
know each other
right so for example let me just take
two sets of triangular pyramid-like
issues
there is apparently
a configuration of a craft
like people who chart these things say
that a lot of these ufos look very
dissimilar but that there are clusters
of things that seem to be highly
conserved over decades one of these
conserved things is supposed to be a
flat equilateral triangle with three
lights in its uh
slightly recessed from its vertices with
round rounded points
okay
then you have this thing with the fact
that the way that these lenses open and
close is with you know some sort of a
and make you you'll have the right
terminology for these sort of
interlinked
um
sliding images of the leaves of the iris
leaves i didn't have the word leaves so
that somehow that the leaves create
triangles
and then you have this
confluence between people who claim to
have seen a very conserved triangular
craft and something that shows up as a
triangular blotch of light and then you
have people who are willing to swing at
any pitch because they're willing to say
oh well that's that thing that was
spotted over belgium or was it
montevideo or who knows what
i have heard many of these stories now
from pretty sober people
yeah and i would never never have heard
any of these stories until i was willing
to make myself stupidly vulnerable
to this topic saying geez i thought this
was all bs um
having now opened myself to that i
cannot explain how many highly conserved
stories i've heard from various people
that
don't show any interest in being public
don't seem to be happy about the fact
that they have pieces of information
that distressed them
it's pretty weird for
yeah
but i i think you know this is something
that has historically been the case and
i think he perhaps might tell us
something more about people than about
what's going on
up in the sky
there was a famous ufologist j alan
heineck who used to be a debunker for
the government and his job was really to
investigate things and figure out what
they were and explain them to the public
but over time
he became convinced that there was
something to it and he largely became
convinced from the eyewitness accounts
of a number of people
but on the way there he did a lot of
research into how easy it is for people
to make mistakes
and he interviewed a lot of people who
were very convinced that they saw
something
but he also managed to resolve what it
was that they actually saw and this is
something that we see time and time
again that
people are deeply convinced
that they their memory or their
perception of an event
is very accurate and they did in fact
see some kind of
equilateral triangle block out the stars
but sometimes it's uh it can be resolved
if you actually have enough information
into something like a blimp or a plane
or a flock of birds have you ever heard
brandon's story
uh brandon brendan fugle yeah
uh which one he's got a couple there's
the the lost time one and
yeah where there's suddenly
the people seem to be paralyzed and
right over the the mesa
not very many feet from his head is a
giant floating metallic structure
i mean
yeah
it's fascinating
where does that where does that come
from it's uh is is there something there
or is is it you know he did he imagine
it is it a dream is it a hallucination
is there some kind of weird gas in the
air that's making him do these things
these these are valid questions i think
he told that story at a dinner i was at
to
maybe there were 12 15 people at the
dinner
at the end of the dinner we walk out and
i'm standing around with maybe 10 of
those people brandon is not in evidence
and we talked about many things
and i said well what did you guys think
of the dinner and nobody brought up
the fact that a
businessman who seems to be ostensibly
normal
oriented towards
family and real estate and all these
things
just described
an unfakeable encounter i mean you know
it could have been that a small amount
of very weird dmt got into his kombucha
but on the other hand
um probably not i just don't know what
that story corresponds to it's too vivid
too clear
it's too unlike
other
things think that the reaction you
described there is interesting to me
from the the other people but perhaps
also from brandon himself um i always
kind of i'm reminded by a thing in
medicine called labelling different
uh which th the beautiful indifference
which is a medical term for people who
have
um
essentially somatic injuries like they
believe that their their hand is
paralyzed or that they're blind in one
eye but they're not but they're kind of
indifferent to it
and
it it's that kind of inexplicable
indifference to something that you would
think they would be a big deal that you
see quite often in in ufos and the
people who see them they they know
they're getting on with their lives
they're oh yeah i saw ufo once and if i
saw ufo that'd be the biggest thing ever
the most
amazing thing in my life and even if
someone told me that i i trusted about
you know told me a story that would be
whoa that is amazing and why is this guy
talking about this you would think there
would be some kind of reaction
but it's almost like there's a little i
don't know attention blindness or
something have you ever had a near-death
experience like a really
i have not no yeah
it wears off really quickly like right
after you have it you think oh my god
i'm so happy to be alive and you make
all these plans of what you're gonna do
and in two weeks you're just back to
normal
yes so yes i've had things like that
with an illness where during the illness
it's the the worst thing ever in your
world is collapsing
and then you get better and it's left
whatever whatever so
i understand that people can screen this
out but
what i'm trying to say is that
by making this stuff utre
stuff that cannot be discussed pushing
it outside the overton window
we're screwing up the science
and i don't do many of these look
i i really hate interpersonal drama and
so in general i avoid these
like imagined dust-ups because i was
never looking for a dust-up with you
which we share too much in common
i'm worried that you're screwing up the
overton window when we need to be
dragging it more open so we get more
information
and the idea that this can be debunked
before it's really understood
speaks to me of how i would
handle faith healing where somebody's
trying to separate older people from
their money by claiming that a laying on
of hands can replace their healthcare i
think i think again you're
oversimplifying it and saying i'm trying
to debunk the whole subject
if it was faith healing that would be
you know a valid argument that i would
be trying to debunk faith healing
because i think faith healing or would i
yeah perhaps other than a placebo effect
is nonsense but ufos i think represent a
variety of different things and i think
there's a possibility that some of them
are you know perhaps interesting
technology from other countries and a
very small possibility that it's uh
aliens and an even smaller one that is
the dimension
because the door is open so let me get
my foot wedged in it like a good uh
encyclopedia salesman from days of old
what if
what if aliens were real uh it didn't
have to be aliens it could be yeah it
could be us
yeah no if if there was something there
in terms of advanced technology that
would be very very
technology
uh because you know if it's not
technology it's going to be magic and i
think technology is kind of the thing to
come to first
oh you're talking about the uh you know
perhaps like some kind of weird
government cover-up type thing no no no
no no slow down
okay
i'm mostly interested in this ultimately
because of science
not technology
i don't think
that
i know anything about their
there's no reason that this has to
involve new science
but if i saw somebody
explode an atomic weapon
before the neutron was discovered
i'd search for the neutron
sure
so right the neutron i covered in 1932
which i keep thinking about my aunt is
older than the discovery of the neutron
what's interesting here is assume for
the moment that that slim possibility
that you and i both acknowledge exists
that we could be looking at alien
technology but it would be built on
science we don't have
not technology because people keep
freezing einstein in which has become
very distressing to me
you cannot go faster than the speed of
light within einstein's construct
but einstein's construct is the map not
the territory we don't know whether a
better map
allows us to do things that are
prohibited on this map but not
necessarily with a better understanding
of reality
so if this were technology based on new
science held by some
civilization that we don't know anything
about could be us from the future could
be somebody from
neighboring galaxies who knows what it's
hugely consequential scientifically and
one of the things that causes me
to despite
wanting to get on with you and
understand each other better you know
also sort of push back relatively
forcefully
is i don't want that window stigmatized
anymore it's like it's enough
sure uh well i think with the technology
versus science question i'm kind of in
the why not both camp uh new science is
great and new technology would indicate
new science but new technology is also
an implementation of that understanding
of those scientific principles which in
itself would be useful and interesting
we should be clear about why i'm saying
there's a general tilt away from science
towards technology
and
there are two hijacked conversations one
is that every time we end up talking
about this it goes to the technology
discussion
because markets have been hot and
science in particular physics has been
kind of stagnant for a long time
and that means that people
inadvertently start thinking about new
technology from old science if we don't
actually keep talking about science the
other thing is that elon
has more or less taken a an imperative
which is that humans figure out whether
we can stop sharing one planet in one
atmosphere in order to diversify our
risk and turned it into a conversation
about spacex and mars
and in both cases what we're doing is
we're taking away from a very real
conversation which is we've got a
potential
you know situation with a dictator who's
invaded a neighboring country as if
the 20 20th century never happened in
europe of all places right next to
article 5 territory this is extremely
dangerous and if human beings don't take
the message from kovid and from putin in
ukraine that we better try to figure out
whether we can spread out because
anything like an airborne
respiratory virus or
you know radiation can cover the planet
very quickly
we're in trouble so it's very important
to me to prop the window open to
is it possible to leave this place
and the the chief reason that we are
unlikely to be able to leave this place
and thus we are likely to die in
relatively short order due to our
technological prowess and our lack of
wisdom
is the einsteinian limit
on travel
now
it's very hard to prop that window open
because people have frozen einstein in
and elon in
and those two individuals have changed
this conversation the einsteinian
contribution means we always talk about
is faster than light
possible which we shouldn't be talking
about
we talk about wormholes we talk about
alcubierre drives we talk about time
dilation in multi-gen we talk about
uploading into silicon all of these
things are useless
right
on the other front
elon has focused us in in the diversity
conversation
to
diversify from all on earth to all on
earth plus mars as if we're going to
terraform mars before elon turns 60.
and
both of these are very dangerous
conversations when we have a very narrow
hope of asking should we be looking
to figure out whether there's something
beyond einstein which gives us
possibilities beyond einstein
so this is one of the reasons i'm most
interested in
the overton window here which is
if einstein's restrictions persist
in the ul to the ultimate theory
we're in a lot of trouble it means we're
probably not going anywhere and we
our only hope is to stabilize this
planet which i don't see much hope in
doing given how powerful we've become
um
and
we have to get away from technology and
from
rockets
and from elon and from einstein if we're
going to actually turn this into a
legitimate question which is is there
anywhere we can actually go or
as is likely the case
we're stuck here
and i think again why not in the why not
both camp there it's uh you know
obviously we need to develop our
technology and yes it would be great if
we had more adventurous
explorations of physics
but i don't really see how what i'm
doing in any way uh narrows the overton
or expands the overtones
i want people i want people who think
they have ufo data
to be welcomed
scientifically
and not stigmatized and made to feel as
if they're
freaked out for me
if people have ufo data yeah i think
yeah i personally am very happy to look
at that data i'm not just going to
dismiss it out of hand i'm going to
analyze it
now i guess the question you're raising
there is should other scientists be
looking at this with some degree of
seriousness and yeah there's there's an
issue there there is this stigma in
science
uh but i think that stigma is is largely
well-founded
because of all the ridiculous stuff that
comes along with with ufos
and i think if there was
some good evidence then people like the
uap task force
would have actually brought it forward
and actually done something with it
we're where are our top physicists
uh i don't know
you're a top physicist well you're a
physicist i don't know where you are in
the world rankings but
i'm actually a mathematician but
i don't know anybody in the top physics
community who knows what the hell's
going on here
yeah well
nobody knows what's going on
so it's not like you know they've been
given the evidence and they've studied
it and they've determined that there's
nothing is going on it's that the
evidence
the evidence isn't really very good
what is the fact that our top people
don't have the evidence
indicative of something
um
i i don't know i i think
from my perspective i think it's more
likely that the
evidence doesn't
rise to the level where it would
you would be able to justify bringing in
outside people now if it's something you
know like the the manhattan project
where they brought in a whole bunch of
scientists you know there's a lot of
motivation there there was a lot of
reason to believe that you know the race
for the atomic bomb was a very important
matter of national survival but with
with ufos you know the base level of
evidence doesn't really seem to be there
we don't have this this this huge push
that would be justified if there was
actually this evidence of new technology
or new physics out there which would be
worth trillions of dollars uh instead we
get these stupid little programs with
with 22 million dollars well it doesn't
make any sense that it seems like they
might even not really be
they almost might be decoys for
relatively small amounts of money are
you familiar with the history that
brought in
the great topologist solomon left scheds
and bryce dewitt
and peter higgs and lewis whitton
together where
there were two
very weird efforts
one nakedly anti-gravity um by a guy
named babson
uh no i'm not really familiar with that
but i've heard you talk about it before
the uh kind of this
secret gravity research
yeah
so there there was there was a very
weird thing whereby in the 1950s
there was like if you look at feynman's
uh popular books he talks uh there's a
story called any questions where he gets
a black eye in a bar that was frequented
by bookies and prostitutes
yeah
what he's actually talking about is that
he was going to buffalo from cornell
to an aerospace company to deliver
lectures
and there was this weird confluence
between aerospace
what's known as the general the golden
age of general relativity and all of
these top scientists that's never made a
wid of sense
which almost certainly seems like there
was some sort of program
run through a couple of individuals
named babson and bainson which is
extremely confusing
to bring a small cadre of leading
scientists to discuss
something that sounds like anti-gravity
in the guise of discussing general
relativity anew
right
and
i would dearly like to know
what that program actually was
yeah and i would like more of us to be
talking openly because we know for
example that solomon left schetz was it
was affiliated with this crazy gravity
research foundation
is there a bunch of like classified
documents about that that people have
been trying to get or is there just
nothing there because it seems to me
like david kaiser at mit the physicist
and historian would probably be the best
person to answer that i've never gotten
at this nor have i put in the time or
the energy i've just noted that for some
reason suddenly in the 1950s general
relativity which had been asleep since
the late teens wakes up
as a field
there's a conference at the university
of north carolina chapel hill which
feynman attends
which all of this seems to be spurred by
two individuals
um
one of which
creates the
what's called the research institute for
advanced study to make it sound like the
institute for advanced study the other
is something called like something the
institute for the study of physical
fields at unc north carolina
chapel hill
and there's some weird thing between
the martin
aircraft company wright-patterson air
force base a bunch of these sorts of
things
and i never even heard anyone talk about
them to put it all together until i
talked to kaiser and i said am i losing
my mind
he's like no no this is this really
weird history where
the great i mean just to put a weird
period on it the the
top mind in theoretical physics is the
son of the leading anti-gravity
researcher from the 1950s it's a very
bizarre state of affairs
i guess you've got to try to think
what's what might have actually happened
there and from my perspective it kind of
the most likely hypothesis i'm just
closing this out there is that there was
a
research program into something that was
quite extraordinary
but it didn't pan out
in the same way that
project stargate was a research program
into remote viewing you know this is
obviously a bit more hard science but it
was something they thought oh the
russians are going to be looking into
this type of thing we too should form a
working group maybe two working groups
and try to figure out if we can figure
out what they figured out and they look
into it but you know the same way that
stargate nothing happened nothing
happens there but it's classified stays
classified and it's a mystery i mean no
technology that we know of is
anti-gravity nothing apparently came
from it unless there's this weird
parallel track of science
that is going on
anti-gravity may be a head fake which
means
that it's really just
post-space-time
physics
it's now become very fashionable in
theoretical physics
to say that space-time is the problem
and that it's doomed as a concept and
that what we're looking for is the
successor to einstein's sort of fabric
for reality
um it may be that anti-gravity is a
really bad name for something to make it
sound junky
but that what we're really talking about
and particularly the presence of left
shots is very interesting here
that what we may be discussing is a post
romanian or pseudo-romanian
understanding of of space-time just a
geometric replacement
yeah and i heard you talk on brian
keating's show about how you thought
that might be
kind of related to ufos in a way and
that
uh whatever the ufos are
kind of represents
a someone who has access to that higher
level understanding that's above
yeah or it could be that it's all
nonsense and it's all disinformation i
mean look i'm very open-minded about
this
uh i was in a discussion with sam harris
not too long ago and he said that
one of the characteristics that he had
noticed that differentiate us is that he
tends to be very closed on the way in
relative to my openness on the way in
but that he notes that i don't tend to
slide all the way down the slippery
slope to say yeah it's definitely aliens
and
what i'm trying to do is really to keep
that
possibility
open that what we're talking about is
we're talking about a science program
not a technology program not a defense
program
that has
technological and military and security
implications
see yeah i i
i'm all for keeping everything on the
table and this is part of my my general
philosophy of investigations i'm glad to
hear that is that i would uh i would
keep like you know uh some kind of
advanced technology new physics uh or
uh or aliens or even things like um
you know say the simulation hypothesis
you know perhaps these things are a
glitch in the matrix that's it's a
possibility
uh it doesn't seem like there's any good
evidence for it but it's something that
you know why not consider that why not
have all these things in the mix because
if you're closing off
various things you might close off
things by accident okay so look
there are minor branches of the decision
tree that i find
so remote as to say that you know
i really don't want to spend time on but
what i'm asking time on it
what you keep it around
well i guess what i'm asking is
do you see any banal
branches of this decision tree
that are still alive i mean yeah well
yeah
i i
think that there's a very big branch of
the decision tree that
does not involve um
you know extraordinary flying craft i
think there's a a large possibility
there's a large possibility that uh all
the ufo encounters
have essentially um
you know simple explanations
uh
and in those simple explanations i would
include things like experimental
aircraft by the u.s government and
perhaps occasionally experimental
aircraft
by other governments but the vast
majority are going to be things like
like airborne clutter people
misidentifying things people having you
know hallucinations from stress like
fighter pilots who've been in the air
for a real long time
things like that
and i think that's that's is
definitely the avenue of this decision
tree of what things might be that that i
go down and i think it's likely to be a
decision tree that has very many leaves
that's probably not the right right way
of putting it because it's still thing
is still like you end up with one leaf
but you don't there's all these
different things you're going to end up
with a branch that has lots of leaves
and all of these things are contributing
to what we actually see people people
see things that are optical illusions
like this triangle thing like a dc8
looks exactly like a triangle because it
has a light on each wing tip and a red
one in the middle and it looks like a
triangle with three lights on the
corners and a red thing in the middle so
that probably accounts for a bunch of
those there's lots and lots of different
things and
then there's also this other layer of it
which is this this government um
you know the pressure from the invisible
college these people who are really into
it and the government people in
government who are either
you know somewhat corrupt they're
getting kickbacks or whatever and if
people pay them to do things or they
just have interest themselves there's
all these complicated layers of things
going on that doesn't really involve
some vast new
hidden parallel track of science or
defense departments like science program
or or aliens or time travels or anything
like that
so i would keep those things as
possibilities
but it seems like to me everything is
probably going to be in this this big
old branch over here okay
airborne clutter
like i have this feeling that we're well
beyond airborne clutter not to say that
i do not i don't know
it's the number one thing that they list
on the uap report it's also the the one
thing that they they actually solved was
a balloon and it's something that scott
bray mentioned in the hearing uh this
this is something that comes up as a
problem over and over again people see
airborne clutter is too far away okay
they mentioned they mentioned four
branches they mentioned airborne clutter
they mentioned atmospheric effects they
mentioned
our technology and they mentioned the
technology of others
and i've gone through this in terms of
the first two are things unintentionally
in the air
the next things are
the first first one includes drones uh
which actually is an intentional thing
that's what i'm trying to say it's not
your born clutter
yeah right so the point is is that the
first two branches the first question is
things that are unintentionally in the
air or clutter and atmosphere right
then the next branch is
things produced by
sentient
life that are intended to be in the air
and that branches into us
not us
and then other and other
therefore is alarmingly interesting
because it's not airborne clutter it's
not unintentionally in the air it's
intentionally in the air and it's not us
and it's not anybody known to us
so my question to you mick is
do you believe that there's enough mylar
balloons swamp gas venus on the horizon
etc etc to effectively remove
just about everything
from
candidacy
i wish you wouldn't say uh swamp gas
because that's kind of um you know it's
it's a red herring a straw man let me
throw it out
it was used to uh explain one case in
the 50s or 60s and it became like a joke
in the same way that seagulls are a joke
so look i just got here
but no i i don't think uh i don't think
it's all seagulls and mylar balloons can
i say that yeah i don't i don't think
it's all like wrong clothes seatbelts
seagulls mylar balloons like plastic
bags and drones uh other things that
were in the the airborne uh clutter
thing uh by by the government i that
does not explain everything i mean i
think there's even categories that they
haven't listed there like distant planes
which are a huge source of ufos my sense
of it is just from people coming forth
out of the woodwork
to me
the stories i've now heard of encounters
are so far beyond
plastic bags
and seagulls
yeah that
i
and again i'm not
if you told me that there was like a
huge theater troupe that was out to
convince us that this stuff was real
sure
but i i can't
process
i don't think there's enough mylar
balloon in the world to explain all the
weird stuff going on no i don't think
they're all things like that i mean
there's a bunch of other things as well
there's these simple optical illusions
like a lot of what people see they see
at night and they describe things like
large things moving overhead or giant
craft
and people's perceptions of things can
be completely off from reality
uh and i think you've got to really you
know this is this is kind of a sore
point in ufology is this this huge
discrepancy between the eyewitness
testimony
and the recorded evidence
uh things like videos you know a lot of
these encounters happen during the day
and people describe seeing things in
daytime
but somehow they're always too surprised
to actually take a take a video or when
they do take a video it doesn't really
show something like what they were
describing because they say oh it was a
little bit further away now
so i think eyewitness testimony whilst
it's an important part of the equation
you really have to
uh
take that with the possibility that
a lot of it if not i wouldn't say all of
it but it depends what we're talking
about
isn't really very reliable evidence and
the fact that it's not backed up with
with hard evidence with uh with with
data with recordings
is a problem the major point in favor of
the debunkers
is the fact that we've never gotten
good evidence i've ceded that to you
from the beginning now the thing that
i'm surprised by
is
it feels to me like you're trying to
take a
twin size fitted sheet of explanation
and fitted over a king-size mystery and
the corner keeps popping off and you're
pointing out that you can fit
one or two corners
and my claim is is that i think that
that ship sort of sailed and i don't
need to be rude about it
wait wait wait wait wait wait yeah
i think
that we're still in range
of some serious disinformation and to
your point yes i understand very well
that we can pile up different
explanations there are mylar balloons
and confused
um sightings of seagulls and et cetera
et cetera but my claim is that that's
that that that works well enough for a
twin size bed
there is a real mystery here and the
real mystery is what explains this
amount of indirect evidence
with this little direct evidence
where
i only find out about the indirect
evidence
when i'm willing to put myself in a
position for debunkers to ridicule which
is to say i'm not
dismissing this out of hand the way i
was two years ago
i've got a hypothesis on on that uh
which is what i think i've shared before
but
it's basically kind of like you know the
cream rising to the top
and what i mean by that is that
uh yeah i talked to
people who are air traffic controllers
senior air traffic controllers i asked
them how many times do pilots report
ufos or talk about them you know while
they're actually flying so it's not like
it's not like they're worried about it
when they get back home
they see something and they will ask you
know what is this thing over there how
many times do you get genuine uh reports
of ufos and this guy been in the air
traffic control for like 10 years he he
didn't have any
i think these things are pretty rare
but
if you take something that's pretty rare
as you know like law of large numbers
and you spread that over
even though what 380 million people in
the u.s
you're going to get
um some hits you're going to get people
who
think they saw something
and become convinced that they saw
something when they actually
didn't see exactly what they thought
they saw
and uh
what we see is this this cohort of
people this large group of people of you
know hundreds perhaps thousands of
people who are really just a minuscule
kind of tip of the spear of all these
possible sightings these are the best
ones you know we've got this 144
sightings from the navy these are just
the ones that have risen to the top
and it looks like a lot say oh we've got
144 cases it's 144 cases out of millions
of hours
of of pilot training but if i ask you to
just live inside your own construct
what are the five
that have risen to the top of mick
west's
that is a puzzling disturbing story for
which i do not have an explanation like
if you were to have to give your own
assessment using the cream theory
what are what is the top five that have
troubled you
[Music]
uh well anything that's not resolvable
but you know there's there's two points
good points to that question one is like
you know my personal experience is i've
never seen a ufo and you've probably
never seen a ufo i don't maybe you have
but uh most people haven't seen a ufo
nineteen what are you talking about i
briefly saw a tiny speck of light that
was traversing the heavens stop in
reverse course i had no idea how high it
was because you can't tell distance
and
it seemed like it was a satellite but
seemed like it's too late at night
it's it would never have risen
to any strong level of interest because
i'm not a sky watcher so i don't know
what's normal and what behaviors things
have
certainly i would never
call myself an experiencer that's not
even a word that i knew but my question
to you is
assume that you and i have never seen
something i assume that curt has never
seen something that is dispositive
what are the top five things that you've
encountered
that
like specifics man not not yeah no
it's like you know what uh
it's it's difficult because
know i got this this general
theory of ufology is that all ufos exist
in the low information zone which is
where you know it's too far away to
determine what things are and the things
that i've been unable to resolve
are things like that yeah i guess the
number one thing uh would be
the
command of david fravor's encounter with
the white tic tac
which is backed up to some degree by
his
wingman alex dietrich who saw something
from above so they they have this
compelling account of an encounter with
a
a flying tic tac that they got into a
kind of a dog fight with
and that's kind of a difficult one for
me to
explain what it is
and i i don't think that's
some kind of alien craft rises very high
to the the list of possibilities but i
don't really have a very good set of
explanations before
around that and i would yeah honestly i
would struggle to
to find more
cases that are similar to that in my own
personal life is that really far and
away what you would say would be
that's number one and there's nothing in
second place
no i mean there's
there's lots of eyewitness accounts
uh
that sound incredible
you can go back through through history
and look at these things like there's
the uh like say if you take the the the
robert salas uh maelstrom air force base
in montana uh accounts on face value
yeah that's
bizarre yeah uh nuclear weapons being
shut off uh whilst the ufo hovers
outside the gate
but i think you know that when you
examine the story and it doesn't really
hold up to scrutiny
but yeah yeah i don't i don't know i
mean maybe you can send some people my
way who are very convincing accounts and
perhaps i would well i just we brought
up the
brandon story and to be honest with you
that one flipped me out because yeah
you know it's like there's no part of me
that wanted to call brandon a liar and
yeah there's no part of me that i wanted
to call him it didn't sound like a
burning man i've been up for three days
dehydrated on every psychedelic known to
man story and it didn't sound like
anything and you know and to be horribly
honest about it
the tv show that's built around the
skinwalker ranch thing
has the effect of turning anything that
happens on that show into something that
can be
lampooned because it's being somewhat
sensationalized as a commercial product
but
clearly they have shown on that show
things that are their attempts to say oh
look there's a ufo right there right
yeah multiple well you you shake your
head
mike
the ufos they show are things like
little white dots in the sky that aren't
doing anything spectacular and they're
probably planes or birds or something
like that they really haven't seen
anything convincing
you had this point about the low
information zone assume that i've
understood exactly well what they've
been trying to claim is that they've
triangulated something in the general
sense of triangulation not the specific
sense
where you know they're showing
extraordinary readings here and i don't
know how they're doing their baselines
like i don't know in general if you pass
current through earth
um
how how unusual that is so i can't watch
the show and learn anything as a guy
who's too far removed from what they're
doing out there
but i think what i am trying to say is
i have now been compelled that i've had
so many weird conversations
with grown-ups
who are
putting way too much specificity on this
once they get over the fact that you're
not coming to get them and make fun of
them they're seemingly like always
looking over their shoulder
because they don't want to be considered
kooky
what
this is how they get you this is uh
oh sorry go ahead good has brandon told
any of you that he's in possession of
high information evidence
but he just can't release it for
whatever reason uh not in terms of
secret evidence he keeps saying that
they've got loads of you know terabytes
of data and that they have some like
things like actual specific
triangulations uh with two cameras with
known angles that they've done but you
know i keep asking him
and he keeps promising and he never
delivers
so
to me it sounds to me like you're saying
that there's only one really top drawer
incident
that is
meeting your levels for saying that's
really interesting and what i'm trying
to say is
there are people who've come forward
which i can discuss like brandon
and their people have come forward that
i won't discuss
that sound quite a bit like this
making
claims that seem entirely inconsistent
with sober
military
just the facts
kind of straight ahead orientation and
in particular
i have a pretty good sense of when
people are limelight seeking
or people are limelight avoiding a lot
of these people seem like limelight
avoiders
like bubbles off
see i have almost no knowledge of bob
lazar
no i'm not i'm not kidding it's not like
i don't know i understand
that he
knows who graham hancock is and
something about chariots of the gods i
don't know anything
this is not my world
no bubbles are is you know i guess
a divisive figure in the ufo community
and uh
a lot of people just think he's a fraud
including me but he presents himself as
very much limelight avoiding
even though he has ended up on various
shows but he always says like it's very
he's very reluctant to talk about it and
if you talk to him apparently people who
have talked to him will say it's very
limelight avoiding but yeah i i do not
want to kind of draw parallels between
those and the people you've talked to
because they're completely different
people but being limelight avoiding i
don't think is necessarily a
a factor that uh increases my confidence
in somebody's story yeah but to be to be
to push back rather rather forcefully
when you have a secret that is deranging
your life
there's both an urge to purge and an
urge to avoid
and you see both of these things in
certain people which is that they're
trying to get back home to normal
you know they've been exposed to some
piece of information you know to be
blunt war used to create divisions where
somebody had seen war and somebody
hadn't and how do they live under the
same roof now that one of them has
seen something that the other can't even
imagine
you know so
if this in fact breaks you out of polite
society
um it's entirely consistent to have
somebody with a basic limelight avoiding
personality who's going to keep going
back to the well
because at some level they're trying to
say i'm not crazy and i you know just to
be very clear about it
part of my
desire to stick up for people out here
is that i watch the
power to silence that comes from stigma
and shame
in particular stigma and shame as
entertainment
um yeah and the idea of laughing at
people like the use of the words clown
buffoon debunk
um
lol rotfl
it
most people can't stand up to this
and
it really bugs me
that an entire group in the world thinks
it's completely okay to destroy an
individual who dares raise a voice
and that's
the non-science reason i'm out here in
ufo territory is is that which is i
can't stand
basically bullying
and gaslighting of people who've seen
something want answers want to ask
questions
and then somehow it's like there was a
secret meeting where everybody decided
the truth and you weren't part of it and
basic attitude towards people who engage
in this kind of gaslighting is fu
science has your back these people don't
belong in our minions
in our community and they have to be
driven out
peter dazek
is in a very
serious position trying to orchestrate
the idea that only
um you know racists entertain the lab
leak hypothesis everybody should want to
know what the hell he was doing in the
woohon institute of virology with
defense department funding
conversely
when we turn over to the ufo community
you know the issue is i don't want
people who have seen something or who
have data
scared anymore
and it's very who are scared of
i mean you keep talking about this
debunking community but who exactly are
you referring to i mean i'm not a person
who mocks people
so that just comes across to me as
playing i'll be blunt that comes across
to me as playing dumb
no i think that lots of people are no no
i'm it's genuine question it's a genuine
question because there's not very many
ufo debunkers out there
i i think it's a it's a really
disingenuous sounding question
i may have i may have you wrong mick but
are you pointing to the previous of this
i can tell you that i find your
interaction unpleasant
it's like i've never
i've never said
i've never said anything like this is
real it's true or did you hear about the
nimitz incident or you know with these
new cameras they can tell that like
that's not my energy
my energy is oh i was lied to
i was lied to about many things for
example psychedelics i was told that you
know acid would uh destroy your your
your body in in your brain
and turns out that it's very well
tolerated um
and even micrograms you know
the the dose needed to kill you i think
is not known because it's so well
tolerated when i found out that i had
been lied to about psychedelics i was
very angry
because i had taken on the trust
that the government knows what it's
talking about and that these were
dangerous substances in the case of ufos
i've been lied to
it is very clear that a lot of very
smart people
have feel that they have had their lives
destroyed over
taking this seriously as a topic
and not by
what
not by me
yeah perhaps by that their colleagues
and perhaps by the the government why do
i have the impression that you
police ufos
uh
i wouldn't say that
what do you mean when you say that eric
what do you mean
i forget what our last interaction was
mick but somehow i tried to say
something general
and you tried to bring it back to like
lou elizondo and chris mellon
and i don't remember what that was but
well does it look it doesn't much matter
but i think what i'm trying to get at is
are you unaware that people feel that
they've been ridiculed and have had
their credibility shredded because of
something that they they sincerely
believe they came in contact with as
either data or a primary experience well
you know i all right let's
let's
kind of in a way show that that question
a little bit because i think we can
perhaps divide uh the experiences into
two groups uh one group would be the
experiencers who
[Music]
are sensitive and would get upset by
that type of thing and you know wouldn't
like uh that and then the other ones are
the people who you know they don't don't
uh don't really care people like david
fravor they come out he didn't have his
life ruined he's given this extensive
discussion uh of uh of his encounter and
nothing happened to him his career was
just fine okay well now we're in
territory where i can map this very well
no things did happen i don't need to
know him perfect personally i've never
met him i've never had a conversation
with him but i can tell you two things
that have happened
one thing is is that people have treated
him as a nutter
and the other thing is that people have
celebrated him as a uh
as a truth-seeking hero
both of these things happen to you out
here
and it's pretty disturbing when people
treat you as a nutter and you're saying
something that's pretty sober like
i was minding my business when the
following thing happened to me and i'm
not responsible for it
do you have the sense that he's lying
no i don't uh i do not have the sense
he's lying most people who have some
kind of experience i do not think that
they are lying but people often say that
i am saying that people lie i think you
know he's telling what he thinks he what
he thought happened
i think his memory may have changed over
time
and his initial perception may have been
faulty
but so you have no perception that
people are paying a personal price
for saying
i was in contact with data i've seen
data or i was i had a direct experience
all of them everyone's been prevented
from coming forward no one's lying i got
the
the cojones to actually step up
you know i don't want to like you know
be little people who who who have
genuine trauma uh from these encounters
and their reaction to the encounters but
it doesn't explain the complete lack
of uh this type of thing or people
actually coming forward
well i mean nobody came forward from co
intel pro and that was a pretty large
operation to stay hidden i mean there's
a
a trope at the moment that the
government can't they're legally
required not to come forward and if you
have a situation in which
um the government is alleged to keep a
secret somebody now says oh i don't
believe three people can keep it secret
much less thousands as if d-day was
never planned i mean this is just
it's sort of this willful playing dumb
that i don't understand it doesn't seem
like
to be honest it doesn't smell like you i
understand your point you understand
your point you know there's this kind of
just chilling effect
of of of uh mockery
i don't think that what i am doing is
mockery and you know i don't really see
um
a huge amount of evidence of some kind
of organized group of people doing it
you talk about this the debunking
community
but i don't think the debunking
community is really having this big of
an effect on people's lives
so you do see the snide remarks or the
disparagement against people who come
out
either saying that they've witnessed
something firsthand or that they just
want to investigate the phenomenon for
example of the lobe so you do see that
there's disesteem at times from
nebulous source
yeah it's like i talked about before
like it's something that's always been
there in ufos it's this stigma which uh
hinders a genuine investigation but
unfortunately it's something that arises
naturally from the somewhat
ridiculous nature of of some of the
stories that are in ufology and some of
the things like the hoaxes and the silly
photos but yeah it's a problem that is
an impediment to serious research and
it's you know it is something that i've
increasingly tried to avoid uh when i've
been talking to people and you know i
get feedback all the time that you know
i come across as being
uh you know perhaps abrasive or perhaps
uh seeming like i'm mocking and i take
you know eric's uh perception to heart
here that perhaps you know my
my uh discussions with people my
encounters with people are not always
enjoyable and i perhaps i don't mind
should not enjoy trying to improve that
yeah
the thing is
i came very close to blocking your
account not
it didn't make me happy because i feel
like you have a lot to contribute and i
really do value
getting rid of um the idea that nothing
can explain these videos because i think
that's completely preposterous
you know we're in a world in which the
matrix and star wars have shown us
things far more interesting than these
videos and the idea that you can't
create these videos any other way is
ridiculous
now that said
i just don't
it's more like the role you're playing
as is like a border collie keeping these
people away from chemtrails and flat
earth
it's like if the conserved quantity
imagine for example you gave grew up in
a religious family i know nothing about
your family i'm not
making this as a point i grew up
catholic
okay
it's entirely possible that in a in a
family in which mythology is rammed down
your throat you better believe and only
bad people don't believe that you pick
up an energy which is i hate forced
belief and i hate it when stories
become so big that people crawl inside
of a story and lose their family and
lose their mind i've met people who've
been in a cult-like environment yeah
their key thing is we've got to make
sure that we don't let any cult-like
beliefs in the door
and then i've grown up you know myself
as an atheist in an atheistic family for
like five generations
and my feeling is in part that that
relentless
focus on let's not believe anything that
can't be just demonstrated in a lab has
its own set of problems
it's very hard to do the cutting edge
research if you can never believe in
your own imagination enough
to let it run wild for a while you know
my personal belief is that we should all
have a creative side and a debunking
side living inside of our brains where
we're debunking our creative
impulse
yeah because it's in part tied to like
ego you know
the issue that i'm having though is is
that the skeptic energy and the
scientific
energy have tilted far enough with the
with what we now believe to be true
that it's really important to me that we
stop scaring pilots who
may
like if you if your explanation is
somebody's under a lot of stress
or that somebody needs a psychological
workup because they might be having a
psychotic break or that somebody may be
hallucinating
a lot of the explanations that may not
involve uap
um
[Music]
are of a personal sort of psychological
characterological nature and to somebody
who might
have as their employment plan that
they're going to fly commercial aircraft
after their stint in the navy
they're not going to want to come
forward
if your explanation uh is effect
effectively that these were phosphines
or the person may have you know had a
flashback from uh
an acid trip from a few years ago
i want people to feel comfortable saying
what they've seen without this extra
layer
well we now kind of have that in some uh
some arenas like specifically the navy
training ranges where we've got a couple
of these videos from
they now have specific guidelines in
place for reporting uh
you know this type of encounter and
they're actually encouraged to do it now
we also have with the faa
a strong encouragement
with pilots to report drone sightings
and they don't need to be necessarily
identified as a specific type of drone
and so we're actually getting a bunch of
ufo reports
uh because of this this emphasis on on
looking at uh drones you know things
that essentially i saw a a it's a happy
accident because of drones becoming a
threat that is a happy accident yeah but
the navy thing was a specific response
uh to the ufo
uh thing it was it was something that
they recognized that there was this
stigma and they tried to they tried to
remove the stigma and that that's a
laudable thing and i think that was you
know it's showing results
let me try to put it
a different
sheen on it so a
last attempt to make the point
i am
very much more careful
i want to figure out phrases i am much
more careful
when i hear somebody talking about
chemtrails for example if they come from
the black american community
then if they don't
and i'm much more
understanding if somebody comes from a
radical progressive family
that went through the mccarthy era and
they don't trust the government
so in other words when particular groups
of people are repeatedly lied to
and manipulated and have a different
history than the rest of the country
i tend to take their
fears much more seriously if you went
through the tuskegee medical experiment
it's
not that crazy to worry about what's in
a vaccine
if you didn't go through the tuskegee
medical experiment if your community
wasn't subjected to that you may have a
very different sense that
you know something's going on or if
you're aware
that we've
experimented with biological agents
involuntarily against people in subway
stations there's all sorts of weird
stuff that we've gotten up to
i forget there was a ship that maybe was
supposed to disperse something so it can
be recorded
the history of secret government
behavior is not a great history whether
it's operation ajax or operation condor
who knows what
and the pressure
not to question these things because the
conspiracy theory
really bothers me because we have a
group that is simultaneously engaging in
conspiracies and not clearing up
things that they could clear up which
does feel that personal destruction is a
good way to keep secrets
and
i guess what i'm asking you is can you
be a bit more charitable
to people who've been lied to
okay
uh that's you know a perfectly
reasonable request i think and uh yes
yes i think i can
and
you know i'd like to invite other people
who are watching this to give me
feedback
on you know whether they like you know
not necessarily just agree disagree but
like in what way
could i do better in what way could the
debunking community do better and what
specifically should we do because i i
interview people
uh who have had experiences you know a
number of
people like you know say kevin day one
of the guys off the nimitz
and uh gary voorhees another guy from
the nimitz encounters different ship uh
but
i'm nice of them i'm not mocking them
what a lot of what i'm doing in my just
day-to-day stuff isn't
like questioning people's eyewitness
accounts i very rarely actually take
cases uh where it's just an eyewitness
account
simply because there's not a lot you can
do with it and it often
it it gets very contentious because
people are very emotional about their
things
so a lot of what i do is just simply the
nuts and bolts type thing of looking at
individual videos and
photos and things like that
so you know if i could do something that
was better in terms of of outreach
to people who have had experiences
yes but i think it's really more about
kind of in a way
avoiding
that type of confrontation because
there's not a lot you can do
with someone who just has an eyewitness
experience someone who tells you i saw
this this this black triangle you know i
talked to quite a few of them you know
kind of online on twitter
and there's only so far you can go
you could perhaps like perhaps do a
hypothesis to what it might be you can
listen to their their explanations and
you can ask them questions about you
know what angular size do you think it
would be like how many hand widths would
it be and you know what time it was and
where were you
but at some point you know you entered
the low information zone and there's not
much further you can go and i generally
just say well i'm i can't really help
you i don't mock them i don't like make
fun of them and in general i don't i
don't mock people
so
i'm sure there are things i can do to
improve
but i don't really accept your
characterization of being part of this
very dangerous uh community
uh i think you you described it as an
abomination that we need to get rid of
the debunking community and in your your
your last thing yeah i mean they think
that the point is that these people are
not necessarily bunco but that's nothing
but you're not i think what you're not
figuring out is
when you come at something from the
point of view of debunking it
right
what you really don't that's what i was
saying from the very start is that you
know with ufos what i do is come at it
from the perspective of investigating it
to try to figure out what that thing is
if someone comes to me with uh a story
of what they they saw but you don't use
the one i i'm
i'm moving away from it you're moving
away i said at the start yeah that uh um
yeah what's his name the the pilot ryan
graves you know he told me he didn't
want to talk to me because i had
debunked you know i always tried to i've
been trying to reframe debunking as a
positive thing because it is about
investigating things to see whether they
are true or false it's not about working
towards a certain result
well maybe think about it from the
following
i understand that
one of the things that's very
interesting to some of us who do
commentary uh on social issues is that
people who are employed by legacy media
outfits
react to anybody who makes a living as
an individual not attached to a legacy
media outfit
they refer to these people as grifters
in order to give the idea that you can
trust harpers in the atlantic but if
somebody is telling you something on the
internet then it's probably nonsense
i think that what you have to understand
is is that bunk and bunko
and the idea of fooling people
i appreciate that you're moving away
from it but maybe a repudiation of the
energy around that
is really necessary because it's one
thing to say yeah i'm trying to use that
less
a lot of the fun
that comes from skepticism is mixing in
this dunking and dragging
and whether or not one is actually doing
the dunking and dragon just let me let
me get to the end of this whether one is
actually doing the dunking and dragging
or whether one is painting a bull's eye
on a target for someone else to execute
i think is really kind of the issue
and my feeling
all right i'm not
yeah i don't i'm not the snark and the
debunking and the dragging like and
you're saying i'm part painting a target
on things by by actually
investigating it and figuring out what
it is and then other people can make fun
of it
that that's you know is that on me that
i investigate something and it turns out
not to be true and therefore other
people
i don't uh perhaps mock whoever came up
with a thing originally i don't think
that
all one has to do is to say look i
really don't want these people ridiculed
well i can't like add a disclaimer at
the end of all my investigations as i
don't make fun of people because no no
look they're gonna do it
there are bunco artists
right there are people who are trying to
deceive other people let's say for
profit
okay sure i think that it is reasonable
to return fire against such people at a
proportionate level
right fair game i think that
well to a point right i mean
you know you
shall also
what if someone is a charlatan and they
are basically selling nonsense for money
then yes i think they deserve to be
somebody's charlotte the the community
has the right to drive their costs in a
particular way up to a point right
but
you know what we're seeing here in my
estimation is that there are a lot of
people
who confide in me and say that they are
frightened or they say i really
appreciate you entering into this space
because i couldn't even talk to my own
family
and there's just sort of no emotional
affect
that i see in you when i'm like i
believe that you and i both know this to
be true now that could be false because
i'm making the assumption that we both
know this
but i have now heard from so many people
that they're frightened by what they
experienced for what they saw
that
for you to say like who's it who's
frightened who's experienced nothing bad
happened to david fair i don't need to
know david fravor to know that lots of
good and lots of bad i don't know what i
said
pardon me i said that there are there
must be some people who are not
frightened by what they saw well they're
kind of divided into the crowd
yeah there's people who are deeply
affected by it but there's people who
just simply will see it as a scientific
observation and they'll be able to
report it we don't see very many people
almost nobody i know who's not
independently wealthy can afford to say
oh that was interesting
would you want a surgeon operating on
your child
if
uh the
the surgeon had had lots of discussions
with aliens sure i mean yeah i would
it's a perfectly normal thing for
someone to see something in the sky and
think it's this weird thing this happens
all the time if somebody told me that
they were abducted by aliens and that
they wanted to operate on my kid i'll be
honest that would tutor my priority i
don't want to take that risk that this
person might be a line
yeah
yeah but like simply seeing a craft in
the sky that is that's a different thing
entirely i think that's a very
understandable thing to happen to people
and there will be inevitably some people
who have some kind of
misperception or illusion
that uh you know it isn't doesn't
deserve mockery certainly not it's a
perfectly understandable thing and you
know i tell people this when i talk to
them that yeah i can see how this
this even even that is a very sensitive
thing even that
they they see that as being
um dismissive
uh so it's it's difficult and like i say
i try to stay away from that type of
thing to your point i think it's
completely reasonable to say we may have
to dismiss some things that are very
deeply personally held
as beliefs and people may get very
injured but the fact is we can't afford
to be taking this as some super serious
threat let's say to our nuclear arsenal
because
mrs o'connell
thought she saw
a cigar-shaped object hovering in her
backyard for half a sec
yeah i think there's there's there's
real serious issues in ufology there are
unidentified flying things
that people have seen and we should
investigate
what
they are all the reasons why people are
seeing these things
and i i agree like let's let's get away
from the stigma of it and then we'll get
closer to some resolution one way or
another i join with you on that and uh i
think that's very positive
how is it practically that we can get
a rid of and get away from the stigma so
what would it require
mick i understand that you don't see
yourself as contributing to the stigma
but do you see that you could
contribute to the removing of the stigma
by let's say
tweeting a repudiation of the stigma
no i think i'm a small fish and i think
very few people are going to listen to
me and you know the millions of people
out there very few people are going to
see what i say
i think it has to come from a higher
level and i think we've already started
to see it like i said before from the
the navy uh by having specific
guidelines where people are required to
report sightings if someone is required
to report a sighting i think it uh it
helps a great deal in removing the
stigma i think inevitably is still going
to be there to some degree
uh and you know perhaps more people
could talk about it
when they make public appearances to
discuss the topic that we should uh
you know not have this statement like if
i'm on cnn again then perhaps that is
something that i should bring up and you
know i think i have i have discussed
that on
on major media that there is a stigma
and it is good that it's being
diminished
so
i don't think i'm going to be able to
tweet out you know stop making fun of
people and people will stop or people
will feel better about it but i think
it's a slow process that we're part well
i think they would
i don't think people would stop but i
think
a large set of people would by the way
just as just as there's excoriation to
the people who come out as experiencers
or people who investigate this topic
there is also fulmination directed at
you and generally people who are
skeptics and i don't like that
personally i think that should stop i
think that that
that that is yeah well that's something
we haven't discussed
not even a single bit today and i i hope
people would
well i hope people would do that less
and i imagine that if
i imagine that if eric that if you said
something not we're not trying to make
this all into let's make public
i'm just hypothetically saying eric if
you were to say that like hey
please please don't gang up on mick mick
is mick has a role to play then people
would be problems
same with me no but kurt that the
problem that we have is is that i've
been in mick's general role historically
it's only been
for like a year and a half or two years
i don't know
this is that i took this at all
seriously at this level i don't think
that my credentials
uh are great from the perspective of
please
the way i see it is what mick is doing
and i said this at the beginning is
a lot of it is yeoman's work
a lot of it is thankless
the skepticism is not that well rewarded
and
it has to be done because we need people
to come up with prosaic explanations in
order to even if it's true you'd want
somebody doing exactly what mick is
doing to say
you know this isn't evidence of speed
if you drag your finger over a picture
of the grand canyon that doesn't mean
it's going hundreds of miles an hour
right
there's all sorts of stuff that is
thankless that has to do with
understanding photography and
parallax and and things that are not
that much fun
the issue is when mick is doing that
it's very important that people not go
into are you telling are you calling me
a liar mode because that's the inverse
of that and that's harassing mick and
you know again
i think mick gets energy out of this
from what i can tell
but it's not pleasant to be called names
and i've seen name calling directed at
mick and that's not right i think we're
making mistakes his importance
is
it really matters
you're not that famous
except in this community
in this community everybody knows who
you are and
if you say something it will be heard
much differently than if you were to say
something about food rationing right
but my point there is that the people in
the community now are not going to be
the ones reporting ufos in the future
because
ufo sighting is pretty much a once in a
lifetime thing
so the people you want to reach are all
the other people who are outside the
community who view it as being a silly
topic that they don't want to get
involved with so when they have a
sighting you know people in the ufo
community now if they have a sighting
they're all like oh yeah i saw this they
posted on on ufo twitter
and that's you know largely my odds on
this but you want how do we get that out
how do we get this message out to the
broader audience how do we reduce the
stigma for the general public and for
pilots yeah
i think i think you can go a long way
towards that because to be honest i
think that you've been doggedly on this
and my fondest hope coming out of this
discussion
would be that we didn't have a dust up
we had a respectful conversation people
can hear the commonality
and that people hear that mick west
believes that
in the interests of science we've got to
make sure that
people feel maximally comfortable i do
think some people are comfortable coming
forward but to be honest there's another
thing that's just about generosity of
spirit like i was wrong and a jerk to
many people in the ufo community
and i'm sorry about that
and it's not just a question of the you
know eric weinstein is so important that
his condemnation of us on previous
occasions really hurt us
it was that i was backed by an implicit
army
of science people who know that this
topic is total garbage
or think they know and
in being an agent for that the same the
same way that i was an agent against lsd
use because i thought it was hugely
detrimental to the brain into the body i
had just been very effectively
propagandized and there's no evidence
that that's true
and there is no evidence in my opinion
that the ufo community um
is
you know
batshit crazy in in reporting these
things that seem preposterous and they
still seem preposterous to me most of
them are not yeah there are a few crazy
people in there but you know the crazy
people everywhere everywhere crazy
people outside yes as i say that with
the chemtrail community is like you know
there's all kinds of people in there
there's people with phds who believe in
in chemtrails there's people with phds
who believe in ufos you know so it's uh
it's
it's not like it's a group of
nerd or world idiots it's just a cross
section of society who happens to
believe in a certain thing
and that should be respected
to wrap this all up what is the one ask
that you would
want either of the other person or of
society so for example if avi loeb
he says
okay we need more evidence there's
something like extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence yeah but
extraordinary evidence requires
extraordinary funding it's a phrase that
he likes to
to state so he wants more funding
that's extremely specific eric what is
it that you want and mick what is it
that you want with regard to this topic
i i want
something very clear i want our top um
quantum field theorists general
relativists and differential geometers
read in
to what data we have
and i would like them to be the
representatives
that actually get go through whatever
data may exist as to whether anything is
moving in ways that are inconsistent
with our physics
i would like to figure out whether this
is a physics issue
or whether this is a defense security
technology public policy issue
if it's physics i want this turned over
to the people who actually understand
where the cutting edge of theoretical
physics is and what's possible under the
twin theories of the standard model
in quantum field theory and general
relativity and gravity theory
i would like to know whether or not we
are seeing anything that is indicative
of
science beyond the science we have
that said
i think there's a small probability
that something like that would be true
the other basic ask
is
that we stop destroying people
um
through our skepticism through our fears
of bunk through our fears of
um a conversation run out of control
it's really important to me
that we recognize that gas-lit people
um
are everywhere and that we need to do as
much as we can to restore that and
whether the end of you know blue book or
something ushered in an era where we
pooh-poohed all of this even if it's
even if it's nonsense or a cover story
that we start treating people who take
this decision tree seriously and not
force them to either say it's ufos or a
psyop but recognize the possibility that
we may be looking at a con confluence of
many different things
and to allow people the freedom to
behave as scientists and invite
anecdote data and disclosure so that the
government really has to realize it's
not their effing information it belongs
to all of us
and it's time to put this thing to bed
in one way or another so that mick
actually gets some great data that he
can go over
uh and see whether it's just uh some
some some bugs seagulls mylar balloons
and apertures or whether there's
something really here and i feel
much emboldened that mick if he saw
something extraordinary
would be likely to say something
yeah uh what he said plus uh what i want
is to figure out what's going on and i
think the best way to do that is to
refine the evidence and i think the best
way to refine the evidence is one like
what eric proposed is to read in
experts on
on various subject matters
but also that doesn't always work
there's been lots of examples
historically where uh experts have
studied uh ufo cases and they've come up
with completely erroneous uh
interpretations of those things as the
famous chilean case which anybody can
look up
where a huge panel of experts couldn't
figure it out
but what happened was that they released
the data they released the video and
then people on the internet myself
included figured out what it was so what
i would like
is for as much data as possible
to be
declassified
and i think that is something that
is not an insurmountable thing i don't
think there's good reason for the
classification of a large amount of this
data when something comes out like this
green triangle video which was
classified you know something that you
know shouldn't have been released
uh there's nothing that's harmful to u.s
interests except perhaps a little
embarrassment where they couldn't
identify stars so i think we should push
for
clarification by having
the data refined
in whatever way
the people who have that data can can
accept you know if it's scientists
that's that's great but if you can
release videos to the general public
a lot of them are going to get solved
some of them might turn out to be gems
some of them might turn out to be things
we can't figure out
but there's there's things that just
basically aren't being done now and part
of that is because of the stigma and so
i would you know i'm agreeing with eric
that that is something that
needs to be
diminished or removed we need to have
people who have experiences
uh or have sightings or even have video
or photos be able to come forward
without fear of recrimination
uh we also you know just to temper that
a little bit we don't want to encourage
a vast amount of low quality reporting
but you know if there's stuff there that
is significant we shouldn't immediately
dismiss it out of hand
and we should try to
figure out what's going on
by refining and examining
the existing data and any new data that
comes over the next few years
we ask the same thing of you
sure i
i
i would like for the invective from each
side to be tempered
when i say each side i mean if one was
to split this into people who are
promoters of the idea that ufos and
what's behind ufos is something
non-terrain it's not
banal
then
so that's one camp and then the other
camp is the more skeptical michael
shermer neil degrasse tyson perhaps even
mick west type though i don't i'm not
going to lump you in there mick
that that side
would would not
inadvertently contribute to the
displacement of the other side
and i see it i see it on both and i like
this concept of
extending and well
to to love thine enemy so even
even people who
dislike you intensely mick or dislike
you intensely eric or just like me
perhaps intensely then
well forget about me i'm not gonna
advocate for myself but what i mean i i
hope that people the vitriol or the
cycle of it to be
accelerated or intensified and it starts
with
tempering
one's own
yeah see i was i was interviewing
someone named salvator pius and
he was
ridiculed by eric davis and hal put off
and i was asking him so what do you
think of
what do you make of their theories then
he said well and he just looked down and
he just retreated himself and he said
well
you know maybe they're right maybe i'm
wrong and i i think that they should be
investigated and i think that their
ideas are worth are worth investigating
and i don't know why they say that about
me but but i wish them the best
something like that and that of all of
that whole podcast that's what's
that's what stuck with me the most
i i just
well that that i think about almost
daily
i i wish that
we would all have a little bit more of
that
i wish that in myself
because i'm an extremely
emotious and
possessive person i'm a rivalrist person
i'm a hateful person
so maybe this is all some way of me
talking to myself and
trying to logically convince myself to
not be that way
well
that's a hopefully there's an answer in
there somewhere
thank you all for coming out
mick
either your podcast's name please
it's called uh tales from the rabbit
hole it's a little out of date but it
does have a bunch of uh ufo episodes
that might be interesting to the
audience here and eric
what is something that
you can promote your twitter
your podcast
i did a guitar video with mike palmisano
but other than that um
the portal is the podcast it's been
quiet recently but i and i think there
are no ufo episodes to the best of my
knowledge
but um
look i i
hope to be doing some things
with you all
in the not too distant future and having
to do with the issue of
what is our best hope for
diversifying humanity's fate beyond one
single sphere and that remains a
question that i think serious people
need to be talking about because it's a
very thin hope
but if we don't get our best people on
our
very thin hope
then we're going to bet all of humanity
on the likes of putin xi and company
and i think i'm increasingly just
unwilling to to see that these people
have enough wisdom to steward this one
planet forward so
stay tuned and let's try to think about
the way in which this weird topic
can both derange us into thinking that
extraterrestrial visitation is around
the corner
or that we're trapped and nothing is
possible and we should probably steer a
middle course where we say
what is true and if we do have a slim
hope
for visiting beyond mars
how would we approach it through science
so that technology can follow
and if i had something to promote
people who are watching this if you're
interested in math and or learning a
little bit more about physics i have a
crash course video on physics which goes
through several different topics you can
look through the time stamps and click
through it also goes through some tips i
have for
what's helped me when i go about
learning mathematics and physics and
different sticking points i've had where
i try to clear up confusion
and it i think it was the video on this
whole channel that took the longest to
produce so i recommend you at least
check it out
thank you all
okay thank you kurt thank you mick
thank you thank you for a very
interesting and uh
illuminating discussion
all right
so anything that
any comments anything you'd like me to
take out
i'm good well i'm i'm great deeply
honored and
well honored is
an understatement to be here with both
of you thank you so for spending so much
of your time
i you didn't get to any twitter
questions
no well
a question i had mick if you all have
two more minutes if this can even be
answered in two minutes is that there's
this phrase the vastness of space or the
vastness of the universe so given that
and our supposed
insignificance in it and scientists
always like to point that out
masochistically